i do want to loot back to uh what's
going on the economy too and not get too
far off the rails because i did have an
article i pulled up while we were
talking about this
my friends i give you the great
resignation why millions of people are
quitting and how employers can earn them
back this is from inc.com four million
people quit their jobs in april alone
money had little to do with it and even
less to do with the earning earning the
right to uh with earning the right to
find the right people for your business
i want to show you this uh this video
this is from trace dominguez i i know
tracy i think it's cool dude he made a
video said i quit you should too the
great resignation is coming i'm not
highlighting his video to dragon in any
way i think his video is actually very
fascinating he shows the microsoft work
trend index 41 of the global workforce
are considering a job change the next
year with 46 planning to make a major
career transition the reason i show the
video is because among
this you know uh i guess
i don't i don't know he's a youtuber you
know i met him at discovery but among
him and his
friends in his circle and his worldview
he's advocating for people to quit their
jobs
now that inc.com said it's not about
money i'll tell you this it's not about
money the reason it's not about money is
because unemployment and the eviction
moratorium have given people the
opportunity to consider things outside
of money
because of that
it is because of the unemployment but
people aren't looking for work because
of money because they have it so when
wendy says we'll give you a thousand
dollars like it's not about the money
why because they have money and they
don't have to pay rent not everybody but
a lot
that's why we for instance at teamcast
we're slammed with resumes non-stop all
day every day and people saying they
would work for a really low wage and
stuff like that we don't do that but we
get people saying like i want to work
here meanwhile wendy's you know
supermarkets whatever they don't get
that
and that is only possible because
the government is is paying people now
this is a great reset
i'm not i'm i'm i'm all for if this
works out well to the betterment of
mankind i'm not a fan of the
authoritarianism of destroying someone's
job someone's goals someone's livelihood
because you think you found a better way
that's scary to me yeah i mean like i i
simultaneously think that it's it is in
many ways and it has been the rational
thing to do to quit a minimum wage job
um in the world where or if you can
manage to finagle it so you're getting
unemployment because unemployment early
on was like a thousand a week and even
now i mean when you add up state in the
federal booster it's like 700 800 yeah
and that's that's free free money it's
like 16 bucks an hour right so like even
say you had a kid and they were working
a minimum wage job or whatever they had
like a high school diploma you'd be like
go take quit and go do like training go
to go do something that you can change
your job and make more money right like
that's that's the rational thing to do
in a world where you know the reason the
rational thing in the world to do when
you're not happy with your current
salary or your current job and
somebody's going to pay you a lot of
money to not be in that job
can you explain this to me will with
unemployment you pay taxes on
unemployment when you receive them it's
considered an insurance claim they call
it unemployment insurance are there any
other insurance payouts that you have to
pay taxes on
um i mean you're paying your social
security which is nominally an insurance
type thing and also medicare medicaid
but like if you were to get an injury
and then they pay you like a injury
there's a disability do you have to pay
tax on that insurance payout uh i i'm
not sure exactly what the rules are uh i
know i mean because like i'm an employer
i think i pay that right i don't know if
i mean i found it very unethical to be
to receive an unemployment check that's
that i've already paid into
than to have to pay taxes on that check
i don't know i don't know the rules um
so those people it's not necessarily
free money they still have to pay taxes
on it i guess was the sure
sure but they're getting still free
money's just less a lot yeah yeah i hope
people realize that or we can see an
influx of tax delinquents americans got
a weight problem uh cdc says that of the
hospitalizations we've seen so far
thirty point two percent were due to uh
uh were people who were obese i don't
wanna say do two but we're obese we know
that america and many countries just
people eat too much so so what's
happening now we're seeing people don't
want to work fast food anymore
well it's only possible because of this
unemployment stuff if i were to envision
a future where there was substantially
less fast food people were more likely
to garden grow their own food be
responsible for their food and eat
healthier that's a good thing if there
are more if people were able to and more
likely to work on things they were
passionate about i think it's a good
thing i think it's a waste of energy for
people to be working fast food and
places like that the problem is i don't
believe the ends justify the means
so we can we can look at this vision of
this beautiful future where everyone's
eating healthy they're exercising
everyone's politically active to a
certain degree and calm and shaking
hands and high-fiving wouldn't that be a
great future wouldn't these utopians be
great these these utopias be great the
problem is in order to get there you get
some
despotic wingnut who says we are going
to destroy as many lives as possible to
get it yeah i mean there's just i don't
think there's the right to just destroy
so many people's businesses or to you
know dramatically change them yeah of
course um and especially small
businesses like that's that's that's who
this hurts it's like the eviction
moratorium right the end result the
eviction moratorium is not no more
landlords it's no more small landlords
right because you'll be in a world where
it turns out we need to have clout to be
landlords because otherwise the
government might just stop us from being
able to evict terrible tenants so then
you have you just have massive large
when landlording companies like you do
in major cities bazootto avalon all
those sorts of companies blackrock the
government's actually subsidizing them
right now this is this this is what
scares me the most though is that that's
the reason why i pulled up this video
and that article is that
uh i think sheamus mentioned the jobs
we're seeing the openings are from
people quitting partially true a lot of
people are quitting some of these jobs
are new with companies popping up saying
we need to hire people but when you
combine the fact that people want to
quit people are quitting and then people
are advocating for others to quit if you
think the economy is good right now yeah
you must be watching cnn yeah no i was
going to say anything
that's good i would say it's also
extremely dangerous i mean look we had
an economy which had many flaws
and some would even argue in some ways
was a house of cards just based on its
its foundations with the federal reserve
banking system but that's a whole other
topic to get into i think the point is
generally speaking the people who owned
businesses a large number of them were
people who took initiative early on
they decided that they were going to
forego immediate reward
and
work for years and years on something
that they would not see a financial
return on for quite a bit which is how
it goes for a small business owner and
many of those people had their
businesses shut down and now we have an
economy that's sort of been rerouted
where anyone can quit their job and
without going through the pain and
suffering that used to be required to
build a business be able to do so but i
don't know that that's gonna weed people
out the way the system used to so that
only the most dedicated people who
really believe in their vision are
engaging in that i think a lot of people
who really aren't made to run their own
business are just gonna end up wasting a
lot of time and tax money well they're
gonna i i don't i don't know what's
gonna happen uh to those people we're
gonna sit around and just eat food you
know just buy things and extract from
the system and then those who work who
who want to work are just basically
fueling and funding the people who don't
work that's not sustainable no of that
so this is this i've talked about this
for for for decades now basically since
i was a kid the philosophical
consequences of technological
advancement
when you get to the point where you you
start removing eliminating jobs due to
automation robotics etc
those people are going to lose their
jobs and it's not their fault you could
you could spend 20 years as a master of
this you know i don't know a lathe or
whatever lathe master whatever those
jobs are called cutting rocks
and then one day they're like we got a
robot that can do it faster and better
than you so you're fired where are you
gonna go work
you're gonna you you're you had a great
salary maybe you're making six figures
running this plant now they're firing
you where are you gonna go learn to code
no it's not gonna happen so now we have
people who through no fault of their own
who played by the rules did everything
right they're now in serious trouble
suppose you could argue they should have
saved better well not everybody can
and so we have to ask ourselves like how
do we transition
to making sure people don't lose access
to the economy and resources when we
make them obsolete through technological
development the problem is there is no
point at which we flip the switch on
it's not like everybody's got to work
right now and technology advanced so
flip not known works no people will
stuff to make food people will stop to
grow food farmers will stop the farm uh
people picking crops will stop to pick
those crops but the people in new york
city the people who write garbage
articles about celebrities oh they can
stop working yep and that's what there's
an interesting point you brought up will
about uh how this is how the labor
shortage affects the rural areas
what are people in cities what are many
of them doing like i look at new york's
media landscape and i'm like these
people produce
nothing
right okay i get it it's a tension
economy it's it's wasting people's time
they're reading articles about listicles
of pictures of cats no joke i mean
they're like i found 12 pictures of cats
and we're going to say these cats all
look like famous historical figures and
they get paid to do that they have
produced
nothing
meanwhile the people in the rural areas
the people who are farming the people
who are mining the people in
construction the plumbers the
firefighters the cops the contractors
they do hard work constructing and
building and making things for society
that's not getting automated anytime
soon
but those jobs we have ai writing
garbage articles those people get free
money and they're chilling in their
cities and it's not a big deal for them
everyone else that gets left they get
left holding the stick eventually people
are going to say hey wait a minute i'm
growing all this food and you're just
taking it from me
that's not going to last very long yeah
well in something you said sort of
touches on something i mentioned earlier
but didn't really get into i mentioned
our economy kind of being built on a
house of cards and you were talking
about savings the fact that a lot of
people's businesses got shut down and
maybe they could have saved more well
unfortunately our economy has been
structured in a way which
disincentivizes saving and that goes
into this mentality of
not wanting people to build the
necessary virtue of deferring
gratification or i mean i should really
say in many ways that's the basis of all
virtue but
we have a system where it's not exactly
a shock that people are going to be
inclined towards becoming takers rather
than makers as soon as the opportunity
presents itself because we haven't
exactly set things up in a way that
incentivizes responsibility even if you
had saved enough to keep your business
afloat for example five percent of all
of your savings would be gone today from
last year without you spending a penny
but max keiser he said he thinks it was
like what ten to fourteen percent he
thinks the government's lying about the
number yeah because that would cause
social security discipline to skyrocket
so they're in panic mode and how would
they pay for social security probably
print more money
and then the inflation gets worse and
then they acknowledge the inflation's
worse and social security goes up this
is what i said the other day if you give
someone 300 for free and they're like
hey that that buys me groceries for the
week
they'll they'll gladly accept it
and then within a month or two however
long now they're like 300 bucks that
covers half my groceries for the week
then in a few months 300 bucks wow
that's a free cheeseburger yeah no
matter how much the currency in flights
and no matter how much the currency is
devalued they'll still accept free money
if it gets them something of value and
so i think i've mentioned this on the
show before but even the people with
this modern monetary theory fantasy
acknowledge that if your economy isn't
productive
printing more money is going to lead
towards inflation so even the people
with the most permissive monetary policy
imaginable would tell you that we're
going to get inflation out of what just
happened over the past year and we're
going to continue to get inflation right
yeah we didn't we didn't get more
productive yeah we were way less
productive
and you know maybe that's a price we're
willing to pay because and i mean i
think in terms of especially when you're
talking about the beginning of the
pandemic a ton of people toss out of
their jobs and effectively having their
livelihoods taken from them as a result
of government regulations and lockdowns
okay yeah we should compensate them
right the way the way i always viewed
that was the government shutting down
your restaurant that's a taking that you
need to be compensated for right
um
but
i that doesn't mean that that's a
continuing thing and i think like what
the democrats want to do it's one of the
reasons biden's so terrible is they just
want to like pretend that it's you know
it's still pandemic world and we should
just open the floodgates and spend
another 10 trillion
well i think they realized that they
could get away with it without people
doing much yeah thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you